das mobile Flugabwehrsystem der
Bundeswehr das ist es was die Ukraine
gerade brauchen und eines dieser
Abwehrsysteme hat Deutschland ja bereits
geliefert drei weitere sollen jetzt im
nächsten Jahr folgen und den
ukrainischen Luftraum gegen russische
Raketenangriffe schützen er Kosten pro
Einheit rund 140 Millionen Euro und die
Flugabwehrsysteme die schützen auch vor
Drohnenangriffen und ja seit gut einer
Woche wir sehen es immer wieder wird
auch Kiew aus der Luft attackiert und
putinsziel ganz klar die kritische
Infrastruktur lahmzulegen also
Stromversorgung oder Heizkraftwerke zu
zerstören ja die Waffen der Russen sie
treffen immer wieder zivile Ziele also
Wohnhäuser oder Spielplätze erst gestern
musste Bildreporter Paul ronsheimer ja
mitten in unserer Live-Schalte Schutz
vor den Angriffen der Russen suchen es
waren dramatische Momente und in einem
neuen Video da ist nun auch zu sehen wie
die Polizei von Kiel versucht eine
dieser kamikaze-
abzuschießen doch die Drohne sie
erreicht am Ende ihr Ziel und sie
exportiert
mit Reporter Björn Stritzel ist für uns
im Süden der Ukraine
Björn wie gefährlich sind diese Kamikaze
Drohnen eigentlich was genau macht sie
so gefährlich
also wie gefährlich sie sind haben wir
gestern an den an den Todeszahlen
gesehen daran dass trotz dessen dass die
ukrainische Luftabwehr offenbar viele
dieser ankommenden Drohnen bekämpfen
konnte einige durchgekommen sind und
dann eben mit einem ich glaube 40
Kilogramm
Gefechtskopf eben enorm schaden
anrichten können die Besonderheit dieser
Drohnen oder bzw das was sie da
besonders gefährlich macht ist eben dass
sie relativ günstig zu produzieren sind
und den großen Mengen hergestellt werden
können und das bedeutet eben auch dass
das Flugabwehrsysteme wie ihre Szene
natürlich solche solche Drohnen
bekämpfen können ich weiß nicht ob das
da gestern tatsächlich zum Einsatz
gekommen ist aber der Einsatz ist
natürlich nicht besonders effektiv
einfach deshalb weil eine eine solche
eine solche
Bodenluft Rakete deutlich teurer ist als
eine sehr günstig herzustellende Drohne
dieser Shahid 136 die wenige tausend
Euro kostet mit Komponenten die keiner
Regulation auf dem Weltmarkt unterliegen
jetzt in großen Mengen gefertigt werden
können das heißt da braucht es dann
wahrscheinlich andere Luftabwehr
Flugabwehrsysteme möglicherweise der
Gepard ist da ist da vermutlich besser
geeignet dafür aber auch dann ergibt
sich natürlich ein Problem dass man
damit immer nur bestimmte Bereiche
schützen kann und das ein so riesiges
Land wie die Ukraine mit vielen
Großstädten mit Ballungszentren ja das
macht das macht sehr schwierig gegen
gegen einen Gegner zu verteidigen der
auf hunderten Kilometer an einer eine
Front eröffnen kann was beobachtest du
denn bei dir in der Gegend in der Du
gerade bist hat die Zahl der Drohnen am
Himmel in den letzten Tagen signifikant
zugenommen
also das kommt immer mal in Wellen wird
das gestartet sind hier im Süden in
versonnen der Region wird ja wird ja
weiterhin gekämpft und haben die Ukraine
größere Erfolge erzielen können haben
mehrere Dörfer und Ortschaften
zurückerobert allerdings ist es da für
die für die russischen für die
russischen Streitkräfte auch deshalb ein
wenig einfach und auch der Einsatz
diesen drohnensystem weil es da eben ein
ja steppenartiges Gelände ist also die
Fliegen auch relativ tief wir konnten
gestern den Einsatz sehen eines
ukrainischen Kampfjets der mutmaßlich
also wir können es nicht letztendlich
bestätigen aber der hat ein luftluft
Rakete abgeschossen und hat damit
mutmaßlich eine eine russische Drohne
abgeschossen wir haben das Objekt dann
zum Himmel vom Himmel stürzen sehen
wissen wie gesagt könnte ich bestätigen
ob das tatsächlich eine russische Drohne
war ein anderes
Fluggerät aber sehr naheliegend das
heißt man sieht das auch von dort aus
diese diese Drohnen gestartet werden
mutmaßlich dann auch mit dem Ziel dann
die Bevölkerungszentren treffen also
quibery Nico live die nähpro saporisha
das sind ja die Städte die alle in
Reichweite dieser Drohnen liegen und ja
hier eben hier eben unter ständiger
Bedrohung dann damit die Menschen leben
müssen wir uns Schritte aus der Ukraine
danke an dich
[Musik]